how about this cuz I've played the most
Aaron's played second most how about you
ask us questions not watchdogs - okay
can you do that yeah sure
put you on the spot yeah all right so um
I mean how much have you played compared
the Peter I haven't played enough to
figure out the question posed in the
first one which is who watches the dogs
watching the dogs in watch dogs deep
have you played enough to know that
answer
no one watch they get away with anything
they want very much you can't pet dogs
in this one so you can pet dogs there's
an achievement or trophy for petting ten
dogs I did do that in the in a couple
hours I played like a dog came up to him
like the developers like you can pet
that I guess one of the my biggest
questions about it though because I
played a little bit of the story and it
seemed it didn't seem to take itself as
seriously but it didn't seem all that
interesting either right so I mean
you've played more what do you think of
the story so far the story is so
inconsequential it is basically an
excuse for them it's very like humorous
this time at least it's trying to be
humorous this time around right doesn't
take itself seriously the first game was
so dour and dreary and dramatic like
whatever yeah so now the story is like
alright a bunch of pissed-off 2030 some
things
hacktivists they don't like people using
information for profit or to manipulate
people so they're gonna fight back and
it's like two hammy
it's too goofy I don't love that but the
characters are like they're light right
they don't bring you down at all it's
just kind of like alright here's a bunch
of just eccentric weirdos that I can you
know talk to and do stuff and then so
you go out in the world and you take on
these you know stand-ins for google or
like weird tech executives it's like a
bad alternative version of the Silicon
Valley show right if it was put into a
video game in that respect and yeah
you're like fighting on the side of good
right to like help out the public but
you're willing to do it at any cost
which if you're gonna kill someone
you're gonna kill someone while you do
it you know if you want to falsify
evidence and have like police officers
get arrested just because they're trying
to shoot you and have someone else
ask them you can do that like you can
really mess with people and the game
never once asked you to think about what
you're doing like this story is mostly
meaningless
it's just ceteris well that's one thing
I think I heard I think I heard you
talking about it how it was kind of like
it's almost like you just committed
terrorism here's some followers yes yes
it is kind of weird but if it's as
light-hearted as you say maybe let's
just say right yeah it doesn't ask you
to like take any part of it seriously at
all so it's like at that point should
you think too much about it you should
think some you should think about it a
little bit but the game really just
wants you to have fun yeah that's kind
of what I got out of it yeah I think
watchdogs the fun like the sandbox that
part's really good watchdogs the like
story and the theme doesn't necessarily
make any sense just because you are
really kind of an evil son of a [ __ ]
it's totally inflicted and and everybody
like it you do horrible things in the
game like it was a guy just fishing on a
pier and I called a gang hit on them
because it was mean here the seals and
it's their food bit yeah so like this
guy totally gets murder and then the
police show up and there's this giant
like shootout it Fisherman's Wharf like
pier 39 and then the games like oh
you're awesome you get followers yeah
you can't really like reconcile what
you're actually doing with what the
game's telling you you're doing and I
kind of wish the game I don't like it
doesn't take itself seriously but in GTA
you're kind of a giant piece of crap and
you know it yeah and in this game like
your giant piece of crap but then you
have these cutscenes where you're like
oh we're the best hackers ever doing
great hacker stuff yeah I mean you know
just to be a completely cynical this is
crafted it seems like for this sort of
did like I hate to use the word
Millennials right we're pissed off at
the system who are pissed off at you
know society kind of turning the
internet into garbage and then using it
against people so hey we're gonna use
their frickin powers and who cares what
it takes we're gonna let out some
aggression it's it feels weird there are
definitely times where that that
conflict of ideas just doesn't make
sense but it's I definitely think it has
a very strong visual design database
around that
movie hackers from 95m I found myself
being a Gen X guy immediately going to
the plain clothing store and getting rid
of all my clang and turning off the
music and then I had a great time
so if ya like the Themis is very strong
and I think if you're into that visual
style you'll love it and if you're not
into that visual style you'll do what I
did well then so then if the story is
not that interesting you're saying the
visual style is good for some people
like maybe it doesn't resonate with
everyone what about the setting so I
know we're from the Bay Area this is
what I was most interested in I did get
to see a little to San Francisco and I
would plate it at the event but what do
you guys think of a setting it was so
the settings grade they knocked the San
Francisco out of the park and one of the
funny things was when we were just kind
of talking about features to do I was
talking about all the people in San
Francisco like Bush man and like
gold-painted man showed up yeah and all
this stuff and like I think Mary pulled
me aside and she's like most people
don't know who the eff these people are
right like you need to make another
feature so being a San Franciscan the
detail is incredible and you'll be you
know mid shootout car chase and you just
stop for a second be like Oh modern art
museum right and then you just peel out
you know yeah I think you know like yes
there are a lot of things that tourists
will recognize a lot of things that
locals are recognized but the like maybe
apart from like weird intersections that
like stood out to me it is things like
the bush man that I think makes San
Francisco a little weird that even if
you don't know who it is in this game
and you see it you're gonna be like what
and like by and large the world is just
packed with like very odd sort of things
you know like there's there's a great
amount of variety in a small amount of
space and it really helps that there's
so much elevation as well one of my
favorite things to do in the game which
I'm doing now just because I want to be
back in this world is just hop on a
motorcycle and ride around go to
neighborhoods take turns I hadn't before
and see what I find like and that I've
had a graveyard yesterday and I saw like
from a distance I was like is that a
band of homeless people and I got closer
I was like oh those are people
cosplaying as zombies you know in a
graveyard and so then I went to go as
you can take a selfie with them and they
all knew and they like posed as like
zombies and stuff like for the camera
like that was really cool and like I did
there's just so much personality yes
that we see in the real life San
Francisco
in the game but just personality in
general I think that can resonate with a
lot of people I hope so what about the
the size of this because they were
saying like it it's all over the Bay
Area but we weren't actually able to see
the map also when I played or we were
but I don't think capture it or was like
Sausalito Marin San Francisco Oakland
you can go down to Santa Clara Silicon
Valley Silicon Valley oh yeah yeah the
maps like condensed version so Marin
County is pretty much all of the towns
in Marin County smashed into okay and
like yeah like San Francisco I think
Golden Gate Park kind of ate up the
Presidio that's not in there yeah like
for people who don't live in San
Francisco about the left half of it
doesn't exist in the game or it's been
condensed in some way like dramatically
so but you'll run into all the landmarks
like they took the important landmarks
out of all of it
so yeah yeah I mean the world itself is
there's a lot of character to it not a
lot of characters in it are there though
like you ran into zombie people you know
walking down Embarcadero and stop some
woman was like beating the crap out of
her boyfriend's car who cheated on her
it's like oh yeah I saw that as well
yeah um so then I guess we should
probably talk about hacking which is
like the big thing about these games how
is it different cuz it almost seemed
very at least in the first one it felt
very like there's a stoplight you can
hack it there's these barriers that they
placed all over the city for some reason
you can hack it there's drainage pipes
you can blow up like whoa how far can
you take this I guess would be a good
question I only played a few hours of
the first game but from what I
understand the primary differences are
one you can remote control other cars
you can't like power them off so like
you can't like disable a police car
that's chasing you but you can tell it
to go into reverse or to take a left or
right you can also hack and I think this
is new you can hack through cameras so
you find a camera you sort of tap into
it and then any other camera or device
that that first camera sees you can make
a leap so that way you can kind of get
deep into sight you deep inside
buildings and follow these these puzzles
these hacking puzzles essentially but
then there are also hacking puzzles from
the first game that have returned where
you have to sort of connect circuits but
before it was like you'd sort of look at
like a screen that just like had the
thing it was like just a flat image but
now like these puzzles wraparound
buildings so you have to get your
quadcopter like your drone out and
literally fly around a building solving
puzzles which I found to be pretty good
like a lot of times they add like a
timing challenge to it as well so you
have to do it quickly
otherwise the puzzles are you know maybe
a little bit basic but that definitely
from a hacking perspective helped me
want to hack fast yeah I think we're on
the fun things about the hacking is the
transitions that you do so you'll very
you'll like throw up your quadcopter fly
it somewhere spot something then jump to
the camera then find a vent then jump
back through your RC drone out go drive
that up and find whatever it is you're
after or solve a puzzle and I think the
way that the hacking hands off between
different devices and you know different
pieces of equipment is kind of what
makes it more fun meanwhile like you're
sitting there cross-legged and the guard
might just walk up and figure out what
you're up to
so you have that like that time pressure
to it that part of it it was pretty fun
so then it's from what you said from
what you guys describing it sounds like
there's a lot of gameplay options like
you have a lot of choice when going into
a mission is that is that true like you
expand on that a little bit yeah it's
pretty true I mean it's basically like
you know you have an arsenal of guns and
you can go into shooting and you know
the AI is a little bit wonky if you
throw in a little bit of hacking you can
screw it them for the most part you can
hack your way pretty deep into a mission
but they will show you something that is
like you need to physically be present
here like you can't do anything remotely
so ultimately you will have to break in
and then it becomes a question of do you
sneak or do you shoot or do you booby
trap things right which is data falls
into sneaking I would try to booby trap
and use violence as a last resort
ai is really good at taking cover in
this game I was planning on a mix of
normal and hard and you start to run
into enemies that were armored I can
load like ten shotgun blasts into those
guys can't take him down they're still
alive but if I take my bike bike chain
weird yo-yo hybrid thing I can just
choke them out in one second so I would
always try to do that because it was
more efficient and effective yes only
yeah I ran a lot of the missions
creating distractions with violence
which was fun to do
because it's kind of a Midway so
building with the door that was locked
you call in a gangland hit on somebody
outside and all the guards run out of
the door meanwhile you're sitting there
with your droning you drive through the
door when it opens so there's a lot of
ways that you can approach a mission um
and there's like violent distractions
and there's not violent distractions
alternatively you can have a police
officer show up and arrest somebody
yeah dude play around with that that was
kind of and then also I don't know being
someone who loves griefing games I found
that if you drove around in a forklift
with the forklift at its optimal like
height you could actually drive through
a lot of cell sections and they wouldn't
notice you they like didn't care though
this forklift just driving through their
restricted area that is some of the
weird AI in this game like you can do
some stuff that you should not be able
to get away with but you can and I think
it allows the game to be more flexible
in terms of letting you choose your path
and even on the higher difficulties it
doesn't get that punishing really in
terms of like AI scrutinizing things and
one of the other fun things though is
when you're in the middle of hacking
sometimes another player will invade
your game and you have to stop and deal
with them and also like you can invade
other players games you usually want to
watch them and wait until they're deep
into something before you hack them yeah
but there's a problem
yeah that's not alive it was live when
during the review period of the game
okay and then some people started
reporting and I eventually experienced
huge framerate problems that would occur
when seamless multiplayers you're
describing was trying to connect
couldn't get rid of it until you were
started the system and we're talking
like sub 20 frames per second mean is
just you didn't want to play it so
Ubisoft up servers down told us they
should be back before launch but then
last night they said sorry everyone this
thing isn't in the game we're working on
it and yeah so that's why we currently
just have a review in progress up you
know look we're still happy to say the
single-player game is really good we I
really liked it a lot I mean and when
the seamless multiplayer worked it was
fun but without it I honestly feels like
something is missing from this game yeah
and so what basically our plan right now
is where we're giving Ubisoft a couple
days because that is the game that will
be the game for months after this point
you know and
that's the situation we're in but it
really sucks because I love this game
and that really added that extra bit of
just like it made the me feel like I was
part of the world right like something
could if somebody could invade me at any
moment and then I have to stop what I'm
doing immediately and freak out you
don't lose much but being invaded but
you stand something to gain by fighting
back so it's kind of like it sounds kind
of like Dark Souls then and then yeah
because I know they had they played
around with that idea in the first
watchdogs there's like a multiplayer
mode where one person was being hunted
and the other one was trying to blend in
and that's okay yeah and yeah that being
seamless that sounds really cool yeah
hopefully it makes a comeback I check
out our review in progress over at
GameSpot calm and stay tuned in the
coming days for our full review whether
seen this PvP comes back or not you
played the game let us know in the
comments below and yeah that's watchdogs
too